morning everyone seven o'clock very
welcome to join us on the breakfast show
here on Sky News almost three weeks
since Nicola bully took her dog for a
walk and never went home
vanished seemingly without trace this
morning there's criticism for Lancashire
police after they revealed new personal
information about Nicholas struggle with
alcohol and the menopause we'll have the
latest from Saint Michael's on wire plus
the race to replace Nicola sturgeon as
first minister of Scotland begins after
her surprise resignation yesterday I'll
take you through all the runners and
Riders and we'll be joined by the smps
Westminster leader Stephen Flynn in just
a moment it is Thursday the 16th of
February police in Lancashire reveal new
personal details about missing mom
Nicola bully and her issues with alcohol
after they classified her as a high risk
I'll have the latest from Saint
Michael's on wire as it emerges that
officers previously visited her home for
a welfare check
the search to find a new Scottish first
Minister gets underway after yesterday's
surprise resignation by Nicola sturgeon
we're live at Hollywood with the smp's
national executive set to decide on the
terms and timetable for selecting a new
leader
teaching unions Demand Action from the
Secretary of State over the shocking
state of school buildings
the moment a victim's family member
charged at a white supremacist in court
as patent Gendron is sentenced to life
in prison without parole
in Turkey the miracle rescues after nine
days trapped under Rubble
a family's fresh Hope For Justice police
say they'll re-examine the death of
Ricky reel who was found in the River
Thames after a night out in 1997.
one of the great Hollywood icons Raquel
Welch has died at the age of 82 and
up
[Music]
and does this song make you feel happy
according to one Professor it's all down
to a special formula
[Music]
foreign everyone Lancashire police
facing a backlash this morning after
officers revealed new personal details
about the missing mom Nicola bully after
describing her disappearance as high
risk detectives clarified that she'd had
problems with alcohol and that there had
been a previous concern about her
welfare Nicola disappeared nearly three
weeks ago while walking her dog along
the river in the small village of Saint
Michael's on wire seemingly baffling
investigators and the local community
let's get more should we at least a
standing by for us this morning at the
scene hello to you Lisa a lot of
criticism for the police this morning
talking about alcohol abuse and the fact
that she was suffering from the
menopause
yes that news conference was very full
fright yesterday wasn't it and if the
aim was to try to dampen some of these
swirling speculations surrounding this
case it failed and failed miserably now
during that news conference police
mentioned that Nicola had had these
specific vulnerabilities which meant she
was categorized as a high-risk missing
person we've never heard that before and
they wouldn't elaborate further than
hours later they did they went into a
specific detail quite unusual detail
about the problems Nicola had been
facing problems with alcohol bought on
by the menopause that had resurfaced
more recently and meant real challenges
for her family and they said that 17
days before she disappeared they had
responded to concerns for welfare at her
home both police and Health Care
Professionals now they said that no one
was arrested during that incident but
they said
interestingly that it was still being
investigated now this level of
unprecedented detail has been criticized
by MPS and campaigners um saying it is
deeply troubling questioning how it
helps the investigation and saying
should Nikola be found safe and well as
everybody hopes here this is exactly
what these yellow ribbons on this bridge
are for yellow rhythms of Hope then how
what a breach of privacy it is for her
and people questioning whether it is
about Lancashire police managing their
reputation rather than driving the
investigation further forward okay for
now thank you
well also this morning the race to
replace Nicholas sturgeon as Scotland's
first Minister begins after her surprise
resignation yesterday no one has
officially thrown their hat into the
ring yet but the SMP executive committee
will meet later on today to set out the
timetable for electing a new leader
let's have a look at what happens next
Once the first Minister has tended her
resignation to the king
who's done that already the Scottish
Parliament has 28 days to nominate her
successor but first the SMP party must
choose a new leader candidates must have
at least a hundred nominations from
party members from at least 20 local
branches in more than one candidate
receives the required nominations there
will be a postal vote Front Runners so
far include bookies favorite Angus
Robertson a former SMP Westminster
leader now Constitution external Affairs
and culture secretary there he is uh
Kate Forbes Scottish Finance secretary
is also well regarded she's currently on
maternity leave
um Health secretary Hamza Yusuf is also
in the running as well as former party
leader John Swinney currently Deputy
first Minister and acting Finance
secretary
and the leader of the SMP in the House
of Commons Stephen Flynn is with us now
hello to Mr Flynn it's good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program why
was this the right time for her to go
morning
um I think that were made clear
yesterday that of course the the
challenges of high office unless we
forget that Nicola has been a captain
secretary the deputy foreign
taking this decision which has been a
formidable leader of our party a
formidable leader in the Scottish
government as she did yesterday
throughout her tenure she approached her
resignation speech was that typical
empathy worms and humility that's Keen
to personify her leadership of the
Scottish government and you know she's
been a personal inspiration to me and so
many others so it's been a sad thing to
see her take this decision but I
entirely understand her reasons for
doing so
yeah hastily abandoned the party after
mistakes of her own making is what I was
reading the newspaper this morning and a
good day for unions
well I you know I'm a journalist and I
appreciate my colleagues in print him
and if you don't
um they say that well there were
mistakes we were making how do you
regroup from this
it looks like it's necessarily a case of
regrouping we're an incredibly strong
position we're obviously pulling
exceptionally well in Scotland as a
party we know that in terms of
Independence the numbers uh tend to
fluctuate between 15 50 uh just above 50
and just below 50 which I think is
incredibly positive we've had a very
successful Scottish local elections last
year where I think we've got a record
number of counselor so the party's in an
incredibly strong position and more
important than that we've got an
exceptional bunch of msps and Hollywood
one of whom will now become the leader
of the SMP and indeed the the leader of
the the Scottish government I think
that's quite an exciting thing and I
look forward to them sitting at their
agenda and uh and taking the party
forward do you acknowledge it's a good
day for unionism
and I I'm not really focused on unionism
if I'm honest uh like I said I think the
Scottish uh National party isn't an
incredibly strong position and whether
you've listed a number of names there
there's some others who I'm sure May
well be considering putting themselves
forward to be the the next leader of the
party and you know these are focused and
incredible abundance of experience also
like Nicola excellent communicators and
I have no doubt that we're going to be
in a strong position going forward and
that's that's where my focus
understandably lies okay yeah it's
neither time for the SMP potentially
to make
case less about independence and more
about domestic policy
I I don't think we've done anything but
make our case uh about independence
based upon domestic policy because if
you look at many of the challenges that
exist within Society at this moment so
the pressures on our NHS much of that is
born directly from the fact that we are
struggling to recruit people in Social
care as a result of leaving the European
Union obviously problems that were made
by the UK government not the Scottish
government so no matter which way you
look at things in terms of the
challenges we face I firmly believe that
we could do things much better if we had
the full powers of an independent nation
so the two things the domestic
challenges and indeed Independents are
and are interlinked and will continue to
make that case to the Scottish people 25
people a week losing their lives to a
drug death
um the latest figures coming out later
on this year I mean that's not down to
um leaving the European unionism
no it's it's not um and many of those
challenges are born from one of the
cities where I grew up
um which is something which is
incredibly tough to take these are these
are generational problems okay and
there's quite clearly been generational
issues in Scotland in relation to dogs
indeed uh with alcohol the Scottish
government's obviously put a significant
amount of funding in relation to the
dog's challenges it stands there's a
task force which was set off I know
there's a uh a particular Minister who's
tasked in the Scottish government was
trying to to overcome these problems and
we are all focused on overcoming these
problems but these are generational
issues and I think everyone uh is very
well aware of that in Scotland
Nicola sturgeon said that she will stay
on in Parliament will she not be a
distraction by doing that
no I think that's entirely the the right
thing to do and the clusterogene is an
incredibly experienced leader as I've
already highlighted and I think it's
it's a good thing I think the people of
Scotland will be quite comforted by the
fact that she'll be there holding
holding the reins for the for the coming
weeks whilst the parties selects a new
leader and a new and a new first
Minister and let's not escape from the
fact that there is ongoing big
challenges to come and making sure that
there is that that continuity at the top
is very important
you've said that you won't stand as the
next leader who are you back in
uh yeah Dita I'll not be standing
um of course and the the next leader of
Scottish national park needs to have the
ability to be first minister no MP has
the ability to be first Minister for all
these reasons that we're located in
London and not Edinburgh in terms of who
I'm back and I've not seen anyone's with
our name into the into the right yeah
once names start going into that ring
I'll have conversations from my
colleagues see what their policy
priorities are in terms of immediate
challenges that that we Face how they
intend to overcome some of the the
issues in relation to the economy in
relation to the Health Service in
relation to the cost of living cases and
indeed our Energy Future and of course
how they set out their Pathway to to
that independent future and I'm looking
forward to that positive that positive
discussion once my colleagues decide
whether they want to put themselves
forward or not yeah you did say that it
was a party of until riches who would
you like to see uh put their names
forward
I think it would be unfair of Me Kate
particularly given what the first
Minister said in terms of the the
pressures of office and the toll it can
take to put additional pressure onto
someone when they're probably having
discussions with their nearest and
dearest at the moment as to whether they
stand or not and so I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna put an additional layer of
pressure on to any particular uh
individual but what I will do is
obviously speak with them uh all uh I
have indeed there is more than one who
puts himself forward to to be the leader
of the park and engage with them to see
and what their policy priorities are and
their values come forward
do you still think that the next
election should be a de facto referendum
on Independence
I actually think it's there so the party
um was intending on having a conference
on the 19th of March to outline uh the
next stage for us in terms of what comes
next because obviously we've been told
by the UK Supreme Court that we don't
have the powers to hold an independence
referendum despite the repeated mandates
that Nicola Sterling in the party have
won a numerous Scottish elections
um so we need to chart that next course
how do we get to that independent future
now the fact to referendum is obviously
put forward by the by the first murder
storm we were going to be discussing in
debate in the merits of at that party
conference I I personally think that
party conference should be paused for
obvious reasons I think the new leader
should have the the opportunity and they
need the space to set out their position
their values and their intentions going
forward and so that would be my take in
relation to that key I think it's
sensible that we do hit the pause button
on on that conference and allow the new
leader the opportunity to set up their
Vision but in answer to my question do
you think the next election should be a
de facto referendum
like I see I think it's important that
the the new leader uh and there will be
a new leader has given me opportunity to
clearly set out their platform and we
know that it was Nicole sturgeon's
preference to have a de facto referendum
indeeds it was my preference as well
um but I'm not going to time buying the
hands of any potential successor I think
it's important that we have
um or we allow them the opportunity to
set out their intentions uh in due
course and and I'll listen to what they
have to say closely
good to talk to you thanks very much
India for joining us on the program this
morning thank you thanks a lot thanks
um we'll be speaking to Joe in just a
second just want to bring you some
breaking news though uh stand by Joe if
you would um centrica the company that
owns British gas has reported record
profits for their 2022 Financial year
operating profits of 3.3 billion pounds
we'll get more how are you doing with
your gas bill
um we'll get more on that and we'll
update you as soon as we can Joe
standing by for us outside the Scottish
Parliament hi Joe what did you make of
what we heard then from Mr Flynn
and not wanting to give anything away so
far okay I think for Mr Flynn as for the
rest of the uh of the SMP shock is uh
subsiding they're now trying to work out
who and what is next the party's
national executive are meeting tonight
not in person but online to decide on
the the terms and timetable for
selecting a new leader the expectation
is it could take around six weeks but
the last time there was a contested
leadership election the s p was almost
20 years ago that took two and a half
months so I think vaguely put April in
your diary is that at the time we could
get a new uh leader as for the
candidates of course nobody has a sort
of website or promotional video to
launch now because they weren't
expecting Nicholas surgeon's resignation
and of course because it's recess here
it's half term many of the potential
candidates aren't even in the country
one I understand it's in the Caribbean
and therefore maybe hot fitting it back
to the UK as of course Boris Johnson did
last year the one opposition party that
thinks they can get most Advantage from
this is labor Scottish labor because one
senior figure who said there was always
two barriers to the party recovering
north of the Border one was the
possibility of being a government in
Westminster that now looks possible
according to opinion polls the second
thing was getting rid of their key
opponent getting her off the political
stage that of course was Nicholas
sturgeon as to the future of
Independence yes the most sort of
persuasive and talented advocate of
Scotland leaving the UK has left the
stage but also I think worth remembering
K that Nicholas sturgeon alongside Alex
salmon completely transformed the
reputation of the SMP and the eruptation
of the argument for Independence it is
now an incredibly mainstream uh
political opinion and of course a
mainstream Party The Establishment a
party of Scotland that of course is
Nicholas sturgeon's Legacy and it's a
very a good one to hand over to whoever
a six-seater
for no thanks very much Joe thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning Neil O'Brien the
Parliamentary under Secretary of State
at the Department of Health otherwise
known as a health Minister will be
joining us on the program
speaking to Dr Mustafa erdek from the
Turkish earthquake foundation on the
devastating earthquakes which struck
turkey and Syria last week
and later we'll be joined by Martin
Underhill a former police officer
involved in the serapane case in 2000 to
discuss the latest on the missing woman
Nicola bully
education unions have written an urgent
open letter to the education secretary
highlighting the shocking state of
school buildings they're calling for the
government to take urgent action to
ensure deteriorating school buildings at
risk of collapse are made safe let's get
more with Richard Rachel venables
forgive me Rachel good morning to you
what is the latest good morning
well back in December the department for
Education raised the risk assessment of
school buildings in England collapsing
us very likely and there's been growing
alarm for some years now about the state
of our dilapidated schools of crumbling
classrooms particularly amongst schools
that were built in the years after the
second world war thanks to budget
constraints at the time and the
materials used many of them are now
entering the end of their life
expectancy so today a coalition of seven
unions including unite GMB the Neu have
written to the education secretary
Julian Keegan
urging immediate action they say that
pupils and teachers lives are being put
at risk by the state of these school
buildings they want to know how many
buildings are at risk of collapse or
partial collapse they want to know what
the government is doing to try and fix
them and they also say they need urgent
action more funding to go into the
problem as well well in response to the
department for Edge location that say
they take the safety of pupils and staff
extremely seriously they say if they
know of a building that poses an
imminent risk of collapsing immediate
risk is taken the action is taken but at
the moment they don't know of any
buildings that remain open in this state
okay thanks so much indeed thanks a lot
um should we talk about that and lots of
other things with the government
ministers joining us this morning hi
it's great to see you thanks very much
indeed for joining us Mr O'Brien let's
talk about schools very quickly and our
school buildings are literally
collapsing what are you going to do
about it well we are investing across
the piece in uh both maintenance and
indeed new school uh buildings and also
driving kind of reforms by getting
schools to work together in
multi-academy trusts which allow them to
work more efficiently so that we get
more for the taxpayers money so as well
as the physical investment we're trying
to drive up standards by getting those
schools to to work together and
replacing failing schools with better
leadership they can drive up standards
over time it's not going to help if the
buildings are falling down though is it
yeah of course we are making major
Capital Investments across the schools
of State
um or we will of course respond to any
particular issues whether there's any
kind of issue about safety very very
quickly just as we have in the past so
absolutely we we will make sure that
every child at school is safe of course
drugs knife crime today um
apparently home counties knife crime
soars it's soaring and Drug networks are
spreading out from the cities and going
into these home counties you know like
county lines as we as we hear about
what's the government going to do
to try to sort that out well firstly I'm
not sure that's right actually knife
crimes down about eight percent in the
last year neighborhood growing down
about 24 and what we're going to do
about it is today we're announcing
another 400 figures let me just that was
I was gonna give you the national figure
yeah so in terms of what we are it was a
decade ago knife crime in the Home
Country so you asked the question what
are we doing about this so one of the
things we're doing about it as well as
uh criminal projects like project Adder
that are about disrupting the county
lines that you just mentioned we're also
today investing an extra 400 million
pounds over the next two years in drug
treatment because we know that getting
people into drug treatment dramatically
Cuts crime cuts reoffending and so we're
going to invest 400 million which takes
up the total level of funding by about
40 will have a record number of people
put into drug treatment because you know
when I before I was a politician I used
to work with people who were Street
Homeless and I saw the both the misery
of their lives of those people who were
cracking cocaine addicts but also how
chaotic they were for society the
disruption they caused the cost of
society of that acquisitive crime we
know that drugs and Drug addictions are
behind about half of all crime and
that's why by bringing up the number of
people into treatment to a record level
by having that huge investment that will
help to stop crime and and the the
causes of crime really well what's your
view on the drug problem north of the
Border
well in truth the worst place in the
entire the UK for drug addictions for a
long time has been Scotland particularly
Glasgow so this is very much something
that's happened in Nicola sturgeon's own
backyard now
um the policy the policy for this is is
devolved ultimately is on the Scottish
government and I do think that um they
do need to do things uh differently
there and so our approach here and South
of the Border has been to to fight this
on all front so firstly having the 20
000 extra police that we're investing in
will have delivered that Manifesto
commitment to have 20 000 extra police
by March ahead of schedule in terms of
stopping people being released from
prison so quickly sort of ended early
release at the halfway point so that
people serve longer sentences that they
deserve and we have less people coming
out and causing a crime and then also to
get as I'm saying today are the causes
of crime by investing heavily in
treatment so we don't have people
causing crime because of drugs yeah we
don't need to go into the fact that you
know you cut more than 20 or a thousand
police officers and you're just going
back to what you were previously is it
Nicola sturgeon's fault that they have
such a big drug problem in Scotland I
think I would say two things so on the
one hand this does predate Nicola
sturgeon it's not entirely her fault but
I do think that the Scottish government
does need to have a different approach
and to look at what is going on in
Scotland they do have it's not just in
the UK that they have the highest rates
it is really the capital of Europe
um in terms of some of these problems
fault I I always think in politics the
constructive things to say is what
should we actually do about it and I can
tell you what we're doing in England
which is a combination of more police at
the end of early release plus
Investments and this is just one of them
in tackling the causes of crime we're
also doing things like they say for
streets fund that that help people to
make their own neighborhoods more secure
and to tackle some of these problems
locally so we are tackling this on all
fronts and I think rather than just us
saying blame it's your fault we say what
we are doing about it here and what we
think they should be doing about it
there as well she certainly managed to
keep labor out of government SNP really
wiping the floor with labor at the last
election she's gone depends who takes
over from her it's another blow to the
tourist though isn't it well to be
honest with you one of the things that
kept Libra out of government in the last
election was Jeremy corbyn and their own
and their their own and their own
policies though the person who was
trying to make in prime minister is now
their leader so there you go but um no I
don't think it was only a Nicola
sturgeon that was keeping Labor uh from
uh being in there and her going is
something that of course the Scottish
conservatives and the conservatives have
been campaigned for it's an opportunity
for uh for us to do better in Scotland
because I think it is apparent to people
in Scotland now that the SMP are a bit
played out in public services things are
not working if you look at things like
the ferries contract it's a disaster
many of the other things that they're
doing are going wrong and there's a
reason that why nickel is gone now like
on one hand we've always worked
respectfully with her even though we
disagree with her on the other hand you
know her the real rooting through of
gender self ID has been divisive not
just in Scottish politics generally but
within her own party there's been huge
divisions over this things about the
loans her problems have been mounting
for a while so it's not completely
surprising that she's chosen this moment
to go and of course we will work
respectfully with whoever emerges as her
successor because they do currently have
a majority in the Scottish Parliament we
of course profoundly disagree with her
most importantly of all about
independence so we think that the people
in Scotland made a decision they made
the right decision to stay in the UK in
a national referendum that was said to
be a once in a generation occasion that
should be how it is because if you just
constantly campaigning for yet another
referendum that is hugely destabilizing
for Scotland it's bad for jobs for
investment in Scotland I'm sure you have
loving caring women in your life
um what do you make of the stuff that
we're seeing on the front of the papers
today where the police are giving far
too much information about Nikki Nicola
bully and the fact that you know she's
struggling with the menopause and so she
was abusing alcohol I mean is that
really what we need to read about it so
uh it's not for me to second guess a
live police operation or to say what
they they should be doing or to condemn
the way that they are going about their
operation and I'm sure that some other
people involved in this would have a
different point of view and say well we
should have because I heard one of the
relatives saying oh we should have known
about this uh earlier on we could have
searched uh differently in terms of what
we can do for people in this situation
that I can talk about and we are we do
have our Women's Health strategy we are
investing in making things like HRT much
cheaper we're bringing in a prepayment
certificate for that to cut the cost of
HRT and things like that so in the bits
that we are responsible for in terms of
women's health we are a human level it's
not for me you wouldn't want that sort
of stuff about your loved ones being on
the front page of the papers yeah the
other the other thing I probably
wouldn't want is some minister in the
government who is not close to the
investigation started opinion on who
should be doing their jobs how in
different ways I mean respectively it's
just it'd be wrong for me to stick my or
in about how the police are doing the
job on this or uh you know who should
have known what and when I think at the
moment there is life search in a really
potential you know a really difficult
situation there at the moment and uh
okay I know it was one of my loved ones
I wouldn't want all that stuff on the
front page that's that's perfectly a
reasonable point of view but it's not
for me to start saying that the police
are doing the wrong thing by talking
about the situation
um I I can only hope for the best
resolution in this and we can talk about
the things that we can do as a
government but at the moment there is
this search going on still and I don't
think it'd be right for me to start to
first time you've been here in the
studio with me it's great to see you
it's a real pleasure I really thank you
for having me thank you very much we
look forward to seeing you again very
soon thanks a lot Minister thank you
um let's move on to other news for you
uh now and we're looking at some of the
other headlines making news this morning
uh we're just talking about Jeremy
corbyn though won't we um he's hit back
at Sakia stammer's decision uh to block
him from standing as a labor candidate
at the next general election Mr corbyn
called it a flagrant attack on the
Democratic rights of party members in
his constituency of Islington North so
care said his predecessor would have to
stand as an independent if he wished to
remain a member of Parliament
new figures suggest more than two in
five people are rationing Necessities or
relying on help from others to stay on
top of credit payments in a survey the
debt charity step change also found
almost half of people said their
financial situation is worse than it was
a year ago just a reminder that centrica
that owns British gas has just recorded
record profits we'll tell you more about
that in just a short time the University
of Oxford has been awarded 16 and a half
million pounds to research whether
CBD can treat psychosis or psychotic
symptoms the welcome trust awarded the
money to the University's Department of
Psychiatry to launch a global clinical
trial later this year
this happened during the sentencing
hearing for a white supremacist to kill
10 black people at a supermarket in
Buffalo in New York in May of last year
an unidentified family member charged at
Peyton Gendron in court minutes before
he was sentenced to life in prison with
and without any hope of parole
quick look at the weather for you hello
again everybody welcome back to the
breakfast show here on Sky News Now was
this yorkshire's biggest and fiercest
dinosaur uh dating back around 166
million years and meet-along footprint
has been found belonging to a
flesh-eating dinosaur from the theropod
series
um it was found on the Yorkshire Coast
by archaeologist Murray woods and we'll
go on display once conservation is
complete
I can't see it oh yeah I can there you
go it's here you see it quite a big guy
it's going to go on display in the
fullness of time now a little earlier I
spoke to the SMP Westminster leader
Stephen Flynn after Nicholas sturgeon's
surprise resignation yesterday he told
me the party should take a pause while
they wait for the new leader to set out
their new vision for the party
we've been told by the UK Supreme Court
that we don't have the powers to hold an
independence referendum despite the
repeated mandates that Nicholas Darden
in the party have won uh and numerous
Scottish elections
um so we need to chart that next course
how do we get to that independent future
now de facto referendum is obviously put
forward by the by the first motor and we
were going to be discussing and debating
numerics of that at that party
conference I I personally think that
that party conference should be paused
for obvious the reasons I think the new
leader should have the the opportunity
and they need the space to set out their
position their values and their
intentions going forward and so that
would be my take in relation to that key
I think it's sensible that that we do
hit the pause button on on that
conference and allow the new leader the
opportunity to set up their vision
Ali is here good morning Ali what did
you make of what he had to say I mean it
was he was bit trading a very careful
line wasn't he really careful not to say
anything I thought it was quite
interesting I mean you were asking him
did he want to be the new leader I
didn't think he said he didn't want the
job he said he couldn't do it because
he's an MP and of course there has been
precedent in the past Douglas Ross was
also an MP but um Ruth Davidson stood in
on the conservative side so he says he
he can't go for it but I didn't get the
sense that he didn't necessarily want to
go for it
um obviously today it's all about the
direction of the SMP we've looked at
Nicholas sturgeon's Legacy what is the
role of Independence going to be and
this is a party that is being pulled in
different directions we know the
question about where the next election
should be a de facto referendum is at
the heart of this he was saying that is
something that he has said he believes
in in the past but he thinks the process
of looking at that should be Paul's
there's meant to be a conference in
March he thinks that should be paused
while they wait for a new leader he was
very careful careful not to say who he
thinks should that should be no one's
put their hat in the ring yet of course
we've heard all the names uh Kate Forbes
Angus Robertson Hamza Yusuf um various
others John Swinney yeah the return of
John Swinney so I'm saying you know he
could be the king maker he's obviously
been an influential figure in SNP
politics former SMP leader for a while
so today I think things could start to
move quite quickly if we start to see
some people throwing their hats in the
Rings but obviously whoever takes over
has a big challenge that will impact
Scottish politics and the landscape of
British politics already as well yeah
for no thanks very much Ellie thank you
let me bring you some more detail on the
breaking news in the last hour that
British gas owner centrica their profits
have more than tripled since 2021 the
suppliers adjusted gains for last year
Rose to 3.3 billion pounds up from 948
Millions it's likely to have been driven
by higher energy prices of course and
continued success of its electricity
generation and gas production units
now more than a week after the
devastating earthquakes in turkey and
Syria there have been some miraculous
rescues teams rescued a woman who defied
the odds and survived
222 hours just over nine days trapped
under a shattered building in caravan
Mirage
foreign
Ty and her two children pulled from a
collapsed building in antakia as well in
Southeastern turkey
Cordelia has more for us now um hi to
Cody good morning oh my goodness me
every time our viewers see those images
it's just so devastating isn't it
it really is and everywhere you go you
see that Devastation play out okay today
we're in kirikin we're about an hour
from the turkey Syria border here and
just look
you've got these buildings totally
crushed and it's about the livelihoods
that have gone with them you know this
was a restaurant that was popular you'd
have lots of people in the evening
gather it around now this car next to it
is completely gone and I think people
are really struggling now they are
trying to clear things up with their own
hands kirikin is not a place that has
seen lots of Aid lots of search and
rescue operations so people are just
getting on with it themselves and there
is rising concern about health as well
of of Cholera of Sanitation of the water
supply as well and we're here because
we're making our way to that border
crossing with Syria now there are three
age routes that have been made available
the sad met with the UN humanitarian
Chief agreed that vital supplies could
come through the UN say a hundred trucks
have crossed on those three routes but
it's simply not enough so far they're
making appeal the UN for 397 million
pounds more to help those desperate
areas in the rebel held North West and
we're going to try and get a sense of
what the picture there is okay but
Frankly Speaking these are the early
days of the disaster people really
trying to work through their own grief
the trauma we've met children who have
been orphaned by this earthquake who
look totally bewildered yes there are
those astonishing stories of people that
have made it through but alongside those
as well the thousands that haven't and
they are calling or at least coming to
an end some of the searches and some of
those areas but still faint hope in
certain pockets of this country that's
now really reeling from just a
devastating moment in its history okay
um thanks very much for the update uh
Cordelia thank you
we will return to the situation in
turkey and of course in Northwestern
Syria throughout the course of the
program meantime after more than two
decades of campaigning there could
finally be hope for the family of Ricky
real the 20 year olds found dead in the
River Thames at Kingston it's taken
years but now police are reinvestigating
what happened that night shiman hasmore
on October 14 1997 Ricky reel went
missing after being out with friends a
week later his body was discovered in
the River Thames no one was ever
arrested for his death and his family
never received answers only accusations
and discrimination the police officer
turned around to my husband and my
friend and he said well you never know
your child your son may have run away
because he doesn't want to you know be
at home or he may have a girlfriend that
you don't approve of or he winked and he
said he may be gay and then he turned
around and he said well you never know
you Asian people always arrange your
children's marriages and maybe he has
escaped for the past 25 years sukdev has
been fighting for answers I really
missed much up growing I missed him you
know School evenings and I missed a lot
of things but I had to do what I had to
do
she refused to give up and always
maintained her Theory
she believes her son was murdered Ricky
had been out with a group of friends
celebrating a birthday when they were
racially attacked by two men they all
ran in different directions and whilst
the rest of them made it home this was
the last place that Ricky reel was seen
it would take seven days before his body
was found at the bottom of the River
Thames the police concluded at the time
that he likely fell in while trying to
urinate but a jury inquest would later
find that they failed to gather enough
evidence
it's been 25 years but this week the
police announced that it will
reinvestigate and re-examine his case
with fresh eyes to explore every
possible Avenue
and after meeting with the commissioner
himself sukdev is hopeful but weary
actions speak louder than words
so time will tell
Shimon Freeman Powell Sky News
now Raquel Welch one of the most famous
Hollywood stars of the 60s and 70s has
died at the age of 82 following a short
illness
either hasmore
you may not know the film but you'll
almost certainly know the image Raquel
Welch and her fur bikini in one Million
Years BC left an indelible mark on
Hollywood and transformed the actress
into a global sex symbol almost
overnight
for decades she was the star without
whom no party was complete in demand at
all the top Red Carpet Events how did
you come to the festival tonight because
I love New York
that's it nothing intellectual about it
well
she starred in over 30 Films including
Fantastic Voyage and the Three
Musketeers for which she won a Golden
Globe and as her Fame grew so too did
Hollywood's obsession with her Playboy
crowning her the most desired woman of
the 70s though she refused to ever pose
naked I don't really consider myself a
sex symbol I know that I have that sort
of you know sign hanging over my head or
around my neck where I show up because
of that poster and because of the way I
came on the scene and the early part of
my career and you know it's not such a
bad thing but it was an image she
strived to move away from even taking on
a male role on Broadway and confounding
those who thought her acting was based
solely on her looks now were you
concerned I mean such a beautiful woman
woman that you would have a little bit
of a whatever playing event no I thought
that was part of the fun of it I mean
the whole fun of it was that I'm a very
girly girl and so then changed me into a
guy made it even more fun
in later years she went on to become a
successful businesswoman making millions
with a line of wigs but her lasting
image will be as one of the Hollywood
Bombshells and proof they don't always
have to be blonde Ivor Bennett Sky News
Raquel Welch who has died at the age of
82 after a short illness now does this
song make you feel happy
[Music]
well there's a reason for that this song
is top of the list for its Good Vibes
our University Professor called Michael
bombshaw has devised a formula to find
out how happy a song is for any music
box out there it's a major key seventh
chord
and 137 beats per minute
now you know
um also to come you cannot be serious
about whose birthday is today oh no
after the break
[Music]
had suffered significant issues with
alcohol in the past which resurfaced in
recent months joined Now by Martin
Underhill a former police officer who
served as the Dorset police and crime
commissioner from 2012 to 2021 and was a
detective involved in the Sarah pain
case in 2000 hello T thank you for
joining us on the program
um other police over sharing
well you can understand why people are
saying that good morning Kay
um I don't think I've ever seen such a
level of detail released before
um there were various ways they could
have said that yesterday without
completely destroying uh Nicholas
reputation to be frank
and you have to ask why are they doing
that now if they'd release that on day
one it would have completely changed the
dynamic and
the coverage of this story uh and
perhaps prevented it becoming the
Juggernaut Juggernaut story it now is so
I'm confused why they've done what
they've done now
you can understand why some people are
saying it's victim blooming to protect
their own reputation
I can't see how it progresses the case
any further forward to three weeks in to
be frank
um we'll have to wait to see but
um I've got to say this case more than
any other missing person case I've been
involved with over the years has
constantly LED back to alleged Mistakes
by the police themselves
police went to the house two weeks
before that sort of information as well
would suggest a different line of
inquiry surely
it words that ends equally because it
says it was a police car with police and
mental health professionals or health
professionals what that the subtext to
that is that this was a mental health
car uh and clearly this wasn't a
domestic abuse scenario or a drunken
person scenario it was a mental health
uh incident which Nicola was suffering
um that is crucial really I'm amazed
that hasn't been released before and of
course on February the 3rd in their
press conference they hadn't held many
um in that February the first com third
conference they actually said there were
no significant um issues involving
Nicholas health so they they haven't
released it then I can understand in
some ways why it is completely
destroying her reputation it's a big
move to take but if you're not going to
take it at the beginning of the inquiry
why now do it I don't understand
yeah why why might they do you think um
it is to protect their reputation